unfortunately we have other breaking
news this morning and it is as mentioned
at the top of the program another
shooting north las vegas police involved
in a shooting near shadow creek golf
course bianca holman just arrived there
live on the scene bianca what can you
tell us here at this moment
yes well details are very limited at
this moment but we are on washburn near
losey you can see several
north las vegas police vehicles on the
scene in this
residential areas lots of houses around
this area and so details are very
limited but we've noticed more uh
officers arrive here on scene as they
investigate matter of fact we saw
several of them kind of huddled up
together
talking about i guess you know what was
occurring here but you can see yellow
tape is taped off on this street here of
this residential neighborhood
so as we learn more we will keep
everyone updated online and on air but
you can see that this part of this
residential area is blocked off with
several north las vegas officers
investigating this is a confirmed
officer involved shooting so once we
find more information we will be sure to
tweet and update you here on the air
bianca holman live local now